[Applause]
[Music]
kylie jenner and rosalia react to their
voices being used in a viral tick-tock
trend
[Applause]
[Music]
it's fun it all started on the social
media platform when one user combined
the audio of the two celebs screaming
with part of aliyah's 1998 hit track
with timbaland are you that somebody
baby
i'm the man from the big beat hey
whatcha gonna play
the trend is making its rounds online
and on sunday it finally made it back to
the kylie cosmetics founder herself the
24 year old mogul reposted a fan on
instagram who pointed out those screams
belonged to kylie and rosalia so
naturally kylie tagged her pal and wrote
omg with two laughing crying emojis the
spanish singer then shared it on her
account posting four laughing crying
emojis with the caption k which means
what in spanish based on their reactions
seems the ladies had no idea they partly
inspired a whole tick tock trend goes to
show that's just how iconic the
entrepreneur and entertainer truly are
[Applause]
[Music]
and get this the trend is so big even
kylie's two nieces kim kardashian's
daughter north west and kourtney
kardashian's daughter penelope disick
are getting in on it
baby
[Music]
i love it it's pretty good i think it's
so good aside from reacting to the
tick-tock trend kylie has been pretty
quiet on social media ever since the
astroworld tragedy which took the lives
of 10 concert goers at kylie's boyfriend
travis scott's music festival back in
november
but in late december she broke her
silence posting on christmas eve in
support of her mom kris jenner's cover
of jingle bells
[Music]
and on new year's eve the pregnant
reality star shared a reflective post
with a heartfelt caption quote as 2022
is approaching i've been reflecting on
this last year and the blessings that it
brought but also the many heartaches it
held i will never forget this year and
all the significant changes it made to
my life i pray this new year is filled
with a lot of love for all of you and i
hope everyone stays safe and healthy
during this time
seems right now kylie is focused on
welcoming her second child she shared a
number of pics on instagram of her
growing baby bump plus back in september
she opened up about baby number two in a
rare interview with vogue for their 73
questions segment
do you have a name picked out
well we need to find out the gender
first and we decided to wait
what's the best baby gift
best baby gift is just anything really
sentimental what's your biggest
pregnancy craving right now
hmm frozen yogurts and in and out always
stormy excited to be a big sister
she is very excited to be a big sister
[Music]